Je ne réveille pas tous les mecs comme oh
mon dieu, je suis Daniel Radcliffe comme c'est fou
[Musique]
[Musique
] beaucoup d'autres garçons de la classe
savent qu'ils ne lisent que le premier ou les deux premiers
et ces garçons ont raison  trois
est le mien le moins j'ai lu le moins
leur Harry Potter dans ma classe
[ __ ] je pensais que ma vie ne pouvait pas en avoir
mais il était probablement le premier jour de
tournage je pensais que c'était juste une
sensation incroyable de monter sur le plateau je
veux dire  J'étais nerveux j'étais presque
malade j'étais tellement nerveux mais j'ai vraiment
apprécié
[Musique]
la nudité pour moi était à quelque chose qui
venait que le personnage ce n'était pas
quelque chose qui m'attirait vers
leur rôle ou me repoussait c'était juste
c'était juste une chose
[Musique]
J'ai toujours détesté tous ceux qui ne
tolèrent pas les homosexuels, les lesbiennes, les
bisexuels ou quoi que ce soit et je pensais que
maintenant j'étais dans une position très chanceuse
où je pouvais réellement aider ou faire
quelque chose à ce sujet
[Musique]
non, je n'ai pas eu une adolescence normale,
mais j'étais sur  arrondi par l'amour, le plaisir et l'
excitation et des personnes inspirantes intéressantes
oui chaque jour
[Musique]
vous entendez le mot Hollywood et pensez
juste après avoir imaginé le panneau sur la
colline, vous imaginez ces étoiles donc c'est et
c'est très ça fait très long chemin même
quand tu grandis et que tu aimes
ça donc c'est une chose folle
et merci
[Musique]
inférieur un livre incroyable et vital
va être sur les étagères de chaque
bibliothèque scolaire l'année prochaine